at a very high level an investment is
when you're putting let's say your money
now into something in the hope that in
the future you're going to get more than
that amount of money back and the the
extra amount that you get back you would
call your return on your investment now
you can think of an investment in
slightly broader terms where you're not
just investing money you could also be
investing your energy or your time and
you could think of it in broader terms
that what you're going to get back is
hopefully more money maybe more energy
and more time as well in some in some
future world and that's why you can
really view in many situations as
education as an investment the whole
idea here is if especially if we're
thinking about college is if you are
willing to put the time the energy and
the money and there's really several
costs here there's the actual tuition a
cost there's the room and board costs
which is the living expenses the the
food expenses while you're at college
and there's also the Lost income you
could be working over those years when
you're in college so there's also that
lost income so it can be a pretty
substantial investment but the reason
why many folks are willing to do that is
the belief that coming out of college
they're going to have many more career
opportunities ones that better resonate
with their interest and maybe coming
down to financial literacy ones that
give a better return in terms of income
so you might say oh it might cost a good
bit of money it might cost tens of
thousands of dollars or even certain
cases hundreds of thousands of dollars
to put the time and money into into
college and also the opportunity cost of
not working during those years but when
I come out maybe I'll be able to make
two times three times as more just right
out the gate and and maybe 10 years down
the road or 20 years down the road
because it puts me on a career track I
could make a lot lot more than I might
otherwise and once again I would be
doing it in a job that maybe I enjoy
more now generally speaking and I tell
this to my own family I tell this to my
own kids I think that's a good idea
college is a good idea but you have to
tread very carefully when you decide
where you want to go how much you want
to spend and what you decide to major in
and how you end up leveraging that major
into a career because when you go to a
college folks are going to offer you
things like student debt and they're
also going to offer you grants and
things and grants are awesome because
that's essentially people are just
giving you money obviously you have
scholarships as well but especially when
you're taking on debt you really think
have to think about are you going to be
in a position to pay off this debt in
the future and have a good standard of
living that you hope to have given the
major that you choose and given what you
know about yourself and both of those
are really important because sometimes
you might say oh well you know I've
heard people in this major can make all
of this money but there might be a lot
of work above and beyond doing the major
there might be a lot of hustling
involved to to make sure you get the job
and there might be people who aren't in
that situation and you're only hearing
about the good stories there might be
certain majors where people are having
trouble getting a job they're having
trouble paying down their debt and so
when you start thinking about what you
want to major in what type of career
path you want to go into how much
tuition you want to pay at which
universities I really encourage you to
talk to as many people as you can
especially people who have gone down
that path maybe four or five years ten
years ahead of you and if you don't know
those folks ask the college ask the
university is hey I would like to talk
to some of the graduates I want to see
you know I don't want to just take your
word for it a college that you have good
placement into jobs I want to talk to
some of the recent graduates and see if
they were happy paying that tuition
putting that time and energy the
opportunity costs and see if they I
think that was a good path or if they
have some regrets that they wish they
picked another path
now the other thing to think about when
you're when you think about investing in
your education there's often a let's
call it a sticker price if you just do a
web search and you were look at some
University and you'd say well what's the
tuition and what's the tuition plus the
room and board which is the cost of
living and eating and all of the or
housing and eating and all of that
there are some places that it could look
like it's 50 60 70 000 a year when you
put it all all together
now some folks will have to pay that
amount of money which is a lot so you
have to be very careful
um if you take on uh that type of
obligation especially if you're taking
on debt but in a lot of cases you can
get significant financial aid depending
on the University I'll tell you from my
point of view when I was in high school
a lot of the my let's call it my dream
schools when I looked at the tuition
back then in the 90s it was in the if
you put tuition and living expenses it
was about 30 30 35
000 and my family
um my mom was I was in a single mother
household made about sixteen thousand
dollars in the year that I was a junior
and a senior I was like okay there's no
way we're going to be able to afford
that but I applied anyway and the reason
why I did is my sister who was three
years older told me about financial aid
because she also went to a similar
University and you don't know what it's
going to cost you until you get in and
they give you a financial aid package
and that package is going to be some
scholarship maybe some grants and it'll
be some loan and then when I got that
package I realized that it was actually
doable now I still did take on many tens
of thousands of dollars of debt which is
real money and so I took it very
seriously I asked a lot of questions I
tried to do my best to make sure I had I
was going into a career that I had a
good chance of paying off that debt and
even when I was trying to graduate from
college I didn't just rest on my Laurels
and say oh I got I have a good degree
surely someone will walk up to me and
give a job no I hustled I hustled to
make sure that I got a job that put me
in a good financial position so talk to
a lot of people think about these
questions College generally is a good
idea but all college isn't equal all
career paths aren't equal and what you
do with those degrees they aren't all
equal so really think hard about that
but if you do it you'll probably make a
good investment